a barrage of rockets hitting an oil
depot in russia not far from the
ukrainian border followed by two
helicopters russia claims ukraine is to
blame for what would be a first attack
of this war on russian soil they just
reflect the real attention intention of
the ukrainian side and the real
intention for any peace talk initially
ukraine did not deny involvement i can
neither
confirm nor reject the the claim that
ukraine was involved in this later a key
security official said it wasn't them
whoever is to blame it won't help
fragile peace talks which resumed online
on friday
in the south more bad news for the
people of besieged mariupol we are
currently on the move from zappoligi to
go to mario paul this red cross convoy
was forced to turn around as it tried to
get access to the city to escort a
convoy of evacuees to safety
time is running out for the people of
marriott
they are desperately in need of
assistance we are running out of
adjectives to describe the horrors that
residents
in mariopol have suffered ukraine says
three thousand people still managed to
escape the city friday the red cross
says it will try again on saturday but
that russia won't allow them to bring
aid in in kiev a visit from the european
parliament president
this is the whatever it takes moments
just after ukraine's leader vladimir
zelinski shored up his own ranks firing
two generals labeling them traitors the
eu also courted china at a summit on
friday china should
if not support
at least not interfere with our
sanctions
as russia's foreign minister met with
his indian counterpart china and india
two asian powers who remain somewhat on
the fence in this widening global divide
redmond shannon global news london